Asians I need some answers they need
answers now
I just need to ask you a couple
questions new some of them some ask
questions I knew it they stared I expect
efficient again Oh Oh what's going on
YouTube check it out so like I said
somebody asked questions about Asian
stereotypes and once again he just
happens to be another fellow youtuber
who I think is pretty damn funny his
name is Gerry in the be junior drag the
video yer I got answers to your question
so uh why the hell are my parents so
strict
um in the words of most Korean parents
yeah I stood on the swimming across the
Pacific Ocean for you to be stupid okay
Paul you Asian people out there you
already know you can't complain about to
lie to me as your parent because no
matter what you've been through they've
been through something that much harm Oh
Dan I just got shot
oh we see you got the shot by a Buddha
he's a North Korea's I climb up a
mountain in the snow we said oh gee on
my back oh my brother
thanks for saying we could drive even
though I don't believe it's true I think
you've been to chop down bumper
I'm not sure if this is a fact but I
heard they're trying to tell us the only
place there's a farm one what the
hocus-pocus nobody's here what do ya'll
get all this money from it'd be souping
up these [ __ ] Honda's and civics and
cameras and [ __ ] what do we get the
money for all our cars
financially I wrote fascist [ __ ] but
y'all see no no no Olympics long jump
behind jump Brits you've never seen an
Asian in the Olympics come on man but
I'll give you something though well
obviously not gonna be in the Olympics
for long jumps in high temps we're not
average height this fight for three
we got a seven inch handicap before [ __ ]
goes dear home plus when we're going to
those countries like let's be real
Africa after news
Asuna Gobbo they're about 25% torso and
75% legs
could you imagine a long jump or a track
competition against the African in the
Asian be the sorriest and limping feet
I've ever seen in my life big in Africa
the gobble just recently went to Rwanda
and he got me this bright-ass yellow
shirt the goggle and all the color
shirts that you got me you got me the
bright yellow one huh you racist [ __ ]
I'm over here looking like a Asian
Walmart rollback simple come to ball
more through your Barney
why the [ __ ] rice got to go every
[ __ ] why does Rice gotta go with
everything that's a good question I
don't know online minute that section
like that you kind of remind me of a
light-skinned a Bubba from Forrest Gump
rice pudding rice salad rice soup rice
nope rice banana bread why what an Asian
father not like a black you dating his
daughter
don't play the parents were being afraid
of their daughter dating a brother any
dad would be afraid of their daughter
dating somebody seven times decides on
you saying to a tiny little Asian man a
big-ass brother coming after their
daughter looks like the big-ass tree
with legs but let's be real man you kind
of light-skinned you should at least be
able to get like you know one foot in
the door and Korean people like you say
you're like the chocolate I don't care
what nobody say the stereotype is true
don't let no Asian fool you think they
can't fight okay they have your
koume Asians do not have to go to karate
but let me tell you something about
kungfu come who is um is a bluff it
means a lot comfortable scaring is
because when you see a grown-ass man
pretending that he's a tiger that [ __ ]
is crazy
hey don't push me but it's okay here's a
general fighting rule for all you people
crazy always beats strength there was
strength you already know what to gauge
with crazy you don't know what the hell
can happen
somebody might you know get the knife
down the chopping nipple up and sew it
to your back face yeah I never see one
Asian as always at 30 minutes maybe oz
is doing [ __ ] leg exercises ready for
something to pop off you got it on that
one man homie it's true you met with one
Asian person you messed with at least
his immediate family which is about 32
people and you know what I still don't
really understand why a lot of H people
have so many kids I mean it's not like
we're gonna use them on the farms
anymore you know I'm talking other ones
I think you know you know states are
some racist y'all have any more
questions go ahead and let me know I'll
be more than glad to answer but until
then cherry the bean jr. good questions
love your video
holla back negombo I think this [ __ ]
[ __ ] sorry and before I end this vlog
yes that's food back there on the Mac
screen okay
don't be [ __ ] judging people and [ __ ]
what's matter with you what I can't
[Music]
will not look over he goes I'm here
you've been recording the motion this
fire go back in for he wait what I
wonder one more time look look look over
here look over here
[Applause]
give them away give me way give me way
way over you one more time one more time
one more time there we go there we go
there we go
you give us a little perfect way to okay
no kisses no kisses okay you know what
I'm doing
no no no no kiss